MATT MCNEILL: Hi everyone.
I'm Matt.
This is Tom.
Welcome to the session, Here
Be BigQuery at I/O. Just
before I start, I've got a bit
of a confession to make.
I developed a bit of
an addiction over
the last six months.
It started back in November, and
someone internally sent me
an email with an invitation
to "join the resistance."
For anyone who's played Ingress,
you all know what
that means.
I've gone through about
two pairs of shoes.
I've walked more miles in the
last six months than I think
I've walked in the
last six years.
It's been a really interesting
experience, because it's
probably been one of the most
engaging, social, fun sort of
games I've played in years.
And I've been working a lot over
the last few months, few
years, in social gaming,
particularly working with some
big gaming customers
in Europe, Gamesys
being one of them.
And it really got me thinking,
how do you create that sort of
level of engagement in a game?
You look at a game
like Ingress--
how do you get that level
of addiction in a game?
So when I started looking at
this, you see these statistics
that actually have been around
for a couple of years.
But so many games that
developers are building, they
get installed once, and then
they're never played again.
Something like 25%.
And if you're writing a game,
the finances associated with
these-- the real business
of a game--
is difficult.
An average game life cycle can
range between weeks and
months, but let's say
five or six weeks.
When you're planning your
business, that's when you're
going to try to make
the money.
But if you can crack this
engagement problem, you can
start pushing out beyond that,
and everything that comes
after that is profit.
And that's important when you're
really in the business
of casual gaming.
So I started thinking about what
are some of the drivers
around this.
And one of the big trends
that I've seen come up--
and this is some basic research
I did on Google
Trends-- was there's a big trend
coming up around social
gaming and the connected game.
Of course, if you don't have
a connected game, it's very
difficult to actually
make it social.
A game back end enables that
social dimension to a game.
Ingress is a good example,
of course, in
quite an extreme way.
Though there's some other
drivers that came
out as well for that.
Second was-- this surprised me,
actually-- but a lot of
people are starting to create
connected games to push some
of their game logic out of the
client for piracy issues.
So there's a great story in
the press a few weeks ago,
where someone had built
a game simulation--
a simulation game of
a game company.
And what they were able to do
is detect whether the client
had been pirated or not.
And they played a bit of a
joke, and made sure that
anyone who'd pirated the game,
their company went bust.
The virtual company went bust
because of pirates.
And there were all these forums
online where people
were, oh my god, this
game's awful!
I keep getting done
by pirates!
Yes.
It was great.
And this is the sort
of fun that people
are starting to have.
But I think probably one of
the most important areas,
actually, comes out
of measurement.
If you've got a connected game,
you can start measuring
in a way that really has not
been possible before.
And I think one of the reasons
I was really keen on doing
this session is I think some of
the work that Tom's done in
Gamesys is some of the most
advanced work I've seen in
really developing this idea of
a science of engagement,
retention, and keeping those
users playing the game.
So I'm going to hand over at
this point, Tom Newton,
Director of Social
Gaming, Gamesys.
TOM NEWTON: Thanks, Matt.
Hi, everyone.
So as Matt's just introduced me,
my name's Tom Newton, and
I'm a director at Gamesys, and
I look after our social and
mobile games business.
So many of you probably have
never heard of Gamesys.
We were founded in 2001.
We're based in London,
in the UK.
We have relatively quickly grown
to be a market leader in
what is arguably the most
competitive online gaming
market in the world.
We currently have about $5
billion in turnover annually,
and I think this says a little
bit about the stature of the
company today.
We were the first company that
Facebook approached to launch
real money gaming on
Facebook last year.
And we've grown from about
10 people in 2011
to about 1,000 today.
We started investing
in social gaming--
social and mobile, really--
in 2011.
And we've grown that team
organically from, again, about
3 or 4 people to just
over 100 today.
We're currently operating five
cross-platform games--
so iOS, Android, and
on Facebook--
and we're even operating a game
for PopCap and Electronic
Arts, something we're
very proud of.
So today, really, we're just
going to talk about a couple
of the uses, particularly
within the social team.
How we use the Google
Cloud Platform.
I always have trouble
saying that.
So we're going to focus, really,
on cloud storage,
BigQuery, App Engine, and we're
going to talk a little
bit about the prediction
API as well, and how
we plan to use that.
So I get asked this a lot,
particularly by developers.
Why not build a cool
infrastructure?
Why not have big data
projects internally?
And I sort of say, we do, but we
use Google because we like
to focus on building products,
and trying to get away from
building infrastructures.
So really spending our time on
trying to make really, really,
really fantastic games and
products for our customers.
And so we can build with Google
because we always plan
for success, and success
means that we're
going to need to scale.
And obviously, Google are an
expert in building excellent
scalable services.
We really love all
the Google APIs.
Doing an integration with one
of these Google services
really means that through
these rich APIs, you can
really use them as just a
building block, and build a
lot of interesting tools
around them.
And that's something that I
think gives you a lot of
synergies when you start to
integrate your own systems
with the Google Cloud
Platform.
And third, it's reliable.
I think the less software that
I need to run and to maintain
and to monitor, the better.
I'd just like to
sleep at night.
Call me lazy, but
I enjoy sleep.
And when we use Google Cloud
Platform, we just, for the
most part, don't need
to worry about it.
We can trust that it's
going to do its job.
So today, we're going to tell
you a little bit about a new
game that we have, and that's
really just to paint a picture
of what these connected products
look like-- these
connected games--
how they work.
We're going to talk a lot about
the importance of data.
And then we're going to move on
to talk a little bit about
how we industrialize the
learnings that we get from
this data, and build
tools that help
us operate our business.
So "Here Be Monsters" is a
pretty ambitious project.
It started about a year
and a half ago.
It's a social game, but we're
trying to take it a little bit
of a step further and give
it a bit of an RPG feel.
So it's an online MMO, we're
building it for the web, and
we're also building it for
Android tablets and the iPad.
So it'll be launching on the
iPad first, and that should
come in about early September.
We're really excited about it.
So when it's out, definitely
check it out.
So in Here Be Monsters, you've
got an entire world.
It's an isometric 2D game.
You've got an entire world that
you can go and explore.
And currently, I think-- we're
in beta right now-- currently,
I think there's about 3,000 to
3,500 unique distinct objects
which exist within the game.
And so I think the point I'm
trying to make here is that
Here Be Monsters is all about
data, and we're just
constantly pushing new items
that the players can run
around the world and collect.
And once they do collect all
these items, they can combine
them in really interesting
ways to craft bigger and
better items.
So a very, very typical
kind of RPG mechanic.
And why do they want to go
around the world and collect
all these items and build all
these interesting things?
Well, they do it because they
want to catch monsters.
And in order to catch monsters,
there's a trapping
element to the game.
So you can build really, really
interesting traps.
You can travel around to the
right parts of the world.
You can put some bait
in your trap.
And then periodically, you'll
check your trap, and you're
hoping that you've caught the
monster that you're after.
So now I'll just show you really
quickly what the game
looks like.
So hopefully, you guys
can see this.
We had a little bit
of a problem
with the monitor earlier.
That looks good.
OK, so here's "Here Be
Monsters." That's my little
character there running
around.
You can see a trap that I've
set here which is actually
ready to check.
But the point that I'm trying to
make here is that the world
is really big.
This is just one isometric scene
that players can visit
and run around and
interact with.
And everything is interactive.
You can see a couple of players
down there, actually,
sort of standing around.
Some of them are probably
fishing.
I think we broke the game
recently, so you can't see the
fact that they're fishing.
But all of the elements
are interactive.
So they can go around and pick
up-- for example, we can pick
up some grass or a dandelion.
We can go fishing.
There we go, we picked up some
grass and some dandelions.
We put those in our backpack.
And we can combine those.
Again, we can take them back
home, we can craft them into
bigger and better items, and we
can carry on with the game.
And the way that we lead players
through the game is
really through the
questing system.
So players travel around the
world, and they meet
non-player characters.
And when they meet those
non-player characters, they're
given all sorts of different
tasks that they need to do.
So they start off very, very
simple, and then they progress
and get more and more complex,
meaning that you really need
to get out there into the world,
find all these items,
discover them, and discover the
recipes on how you make
better and better items.
Just to give you a sense
of some of the
artwork in the world--
so this is the world.
It's a game that's based on the
real world, and it's full
of isometric scenes that
you can visit.
So if I zoom in, all of these
little icons here, they all
represent unique isometric 2D
scenes that players can visit,
and they're full of different
kinds of items.
There are different trees,
different butterflies,
different flowers.
And I think the coolest thing
about the game, too, is that
the monsters are actually
all taken
from real human mythology.
So if you wanted to find a
specific kind of monster that
you know about, chances are that
it's going to be in the
area that you would expect
it to be in.
But if you need to look
it up, you can
always go into the almanac.
I'll just show you
that as well.
So the almanac--
this is the dandelion pixie,
which is one of the nicer
looking monsters that you can
go out and try and catch.
But there's a lot of information
within the almanac
that tells you all about all
the different monsters.
For example, a chimera, which
is probably something that
some people are familiar with,
the different baits that you
might have to craft in
order to trap them.
So hopefully, this is kind of
making the point, there's a
ton of data in this game.
And the strategy behind this
game is that we built a really
interesting kind of CMS behind
the scenes that allows us to
push a lot of content on a
weekly basis, because we
expect that a lot of the most
engaged users are going to
tear through the content.
So it's very, very important
that if we want to keep them
engaged, we need to be
constantly releasing new and
better content for this game.
Great.
So, all right.
So we've sort of painted a
little bit of a picture.
We've got a lot of players,
they're running around,
they're doing all these
different activities.
They can visit friends, they can
send gifts, they can farm
on their homesteads, they
can craft items,
they can collect items.
So what does this mean?
Well, what it means is that we
generate a ton of events.
There's a lot of raw data,
and that raw data--
I'd say five or six years ago,
you probably wouldn't have
recorded every single little
step that a player made and
all of the different
properties that
go along with that.
But today, it's pretty much
a necessity if you want to
operate one of these games,
and you want to operate it
well and optimize it and run
it as a solid business.
But that means you're
going to generate a
huge amount of data.
And just to give you an idea of
the sorts of levels of data
that we see-- and to be honest,
there are plenty of
other companies that are
probably generating
even more than this.
"Here Be Monsters" right now has
got about 10,000 people in
a limited beta on Facebook.
And those 10,000 players are
generating about a million
sessions a month, and
about 200 million
unique events a month.
So 200 million actions taken
by 10,000 daily actives.
We've got other games currently
that are running.
Game 2 there, launched about
three months ago, has already
got 150,000 people playing
it every day.
They're generating about
500 million events
every single month.
And then one of our larger games
is generating in the
billions of events
every month.
All of this data goes
into BigQuery.
And the reason why we really
like BigQuery at Gamesys is
that it's managed, so there's
almost nothing you need to do
to get set up.
It scales.
I'm going to say this
a lot today.
We really cannot integrate with
a service where we think
that it can't scale, and
BigQuery definitely has a lot
of power and can do the sorts
of things that we
want to do with it.
And then also the fact that
you're just writing SQL.
Anybody can write a BigQuery,
and that's pretty awesome,
because our analysts don't like
training days and this
sort of thing.
Because they already know SQL,
and they know it really well,
the transition is extremely easy
for them to go and start
writing big, powerful queries.
So to give you an idea of what
happens within our platform,
every day, we've got all these
players coming in, they're
playing the game, doing all
these different things, having
a lot of fun.
And at night, we aggregate all
of that events data into a
couple of aggregated tables
just for convenience.
And then we also upload all of
the raw events into a table
within BigQuery.
So these aggregations, these
aggregated tables, they're
there for convenience, but they
help us drive, really,
just high level KPI reporting.
Just to give you an idea of a
couple of the tables that we
use fairly consistently across
all of our games-- and you may
want to define different ones
depending on the style of game
or application--
I mean, I think this applies to
really any digital product.
The first is profiles.
So profiles, when they're
aggregated at night, you get a
picture of what that user's
state looked like at the end
of the day, and that's
fairly important.
Sessions are fairly
self-explanatory.
They're essentially aggregated
groups of events that match a
user's play periods.
And then we have transactions.
So transactions, obviously,
are really important.
They drive the entire
business.
We want to know when did someone
make a purchase, very,
very specifically, so that we
can go and really dig into,
what motivated them to
make that purchase?
What did they do once they
bought that virtual currency
or virtual good?
How did they spend that
within the game?
What sort of activities did they
engage with afterwards?
It's really, really important
that we dig in and understand
the purchasing behavior and the
behavior of our players,
especially around the
time of purchase.
So hopefully, I've been able
to paint a little bit of a
picture about what the game
is, what kind of data it
generates, the volumes of data
that it generates, and that we
effectively every night update
a number of data sets and
tables within BigQuery.
So now that our data is in
BigQuery, and you understand
the structure of that data,
we're going to talk just a
little bit about how--
this is probably one of the
simplest things you can do, in
fact, once your data is in
BigQuery, and that is to
integrate that data
with spreadsheets.
So, to build, essentially,
reports of various shapes and
sizes using Apps Script.
This is incredibly easy to do.
So using some of those
aggregated tables, on our
teams, we build up dashboards.
So we build relatively
complicated workbooks that
everybody on the team
has access to.
We look at a lot of
different metrics.
We slice them in
different ways.
But probably the simplest
would be a simple daily
dashboard, and these really just
help to highlight high
level KPI trends.
And they often give you a bit
of a hint that just says,
maybe we want to go
and look at this.
Retention looks like it's a
little bit off for these
players, or something's
happened, and
our active user base--
the retention dropped over the
next week, and we want to
figure out why.
And other people may want
to look at things
like conversion rates.
So when we have brand new
installs coming in on a given
day or given week, we really
want to monitor the health of
those users, compare them to
other install days, other
install weeks, so that we feel
comfortable continuing with
our acquisition spend.
So now what I'll do is I'll just
show you very quickly for
the developers that are in the
room, of which I would imagine
there are lots of you, I'll just
show you how easy it is
to basically integrate BigQuery
with spreadsheets,
and to build reports this way.
So what I've done here is
I've just given you--
within our games, we tend to
have lots of different types
of funnels.
So funnels, really, are just
sequential events, and the
fact that we've got all this
raw events data in BigQuery
pretty much means we can define
any funnel we want.
And that's pretty significant,
and pretty powerful.
So let's just take this
as an example.
I've called it the elementary
quest funnel analysis.
But let's say we've got
a product manager.
This week, they're going to
focus on a very specific part
of the game.
They think they've seen
a bit of drop-off.
They've asked one of the
analysts to go away and do a
bit of ad hoc analysis.
They've identified the issue.
And now what they
want to see is.
As they make these iterations
daily, and they keep pushing
these releases, we want to get
that data in front of a
product manager.
And a product manager doesn't
necessarily know how to go
into BigQuery and write a bunch
of SQL, nor should they
have to, because our analysts
can simply create a new
workbook that's specifically
for that product manager,
define a query that can go away
and look at those tables,
pull out all the interesting
events that matter, and
summarize that into a sample
little dashboard.
So how do you do that?
Well, to be honest, I didn't
even know this stuff existed
about nine months ago until I
did a little bit of digging
around and had a few
chats with Matt.
But we've started using it
heavily, and it's fantastic.
So you need to go into the
script editor to start working
with Apps Script, and you'll
find it under the Tools menu.
So if you go to the Tools menu
and you go down here, this
script editor thing-- if you've
ever wondered what that
is, well, for those you that are
new to Apps Script, that
will open the script editor.
And what you'll see here is
essentially JavaScript.
So Apps Script is basically
JavaScript.
And I'll just show you.
So this function here is just
a very simple function which
takes a query, which is just
our SQL statement.
I've put it in a comment down
here, just to illustrate the
complexity of the query.
So this is a big
complex query.
It's going query about 200
million rows of data, and it's
going to pull the results back,
and it's going to put
that into our spreadsheet.
So how do you connect to
BigQuery within Apps Script?
Well, it's actually
really simple.
So here's a little convenience
function that I wrote, which
is run query async, and it's
really just broken down into
three parts.
So you've got this job
description here, which is
very, very simple to set up.
And you can see that we're
passing in our SQL statements.
That's just a string that
represents our SQL statement.
You can then insert the job.
So again, very, very simple.
That's basically passing it off
to BigQuery and asking it
to actually execute the query.
And then all we do here
is we just wait.
We wait asynchronously,
and we pull to see
if the job is complete.
And then finally, when the
results come back, we go ahead
and fetch them just here,
and then we return them.
And that's essentially it.
So if we run that now,
hopefully this will--
oh, sorry.
This is one other thing you can
do, which is, again, for
convenience, is you can very
easily just add your own
custom menus.
So you can see this little
bit of code here.
That's all that does.
So I get a nice little menu
item here, and this button
here is hooked to my function.
Now, the other thing I'll
mention as well--
when you're building up, say,
daily dashboards or monthly
dashboards, a really nice,
simple way to get them to
automatically run every day
is with the triggers
functionality.
So this little icon here
is the triggers.
To set up a new periodic trigger
is extremely simple.
Just go here and add a trigger,
select the function
that you want to run, select
that you want it to be time
driven, and there's a bunch
of different options here.
So if this was a daily thing
that we wanted to refresh, I
would select daily, select the
time we want it to run-- so
let's say we want it
to run at 6:00 AM.
We'd save that.
And now this spreadsheet's going
to automatically run
that query for you at between
6:00 and 7:00 AM.
And so when you get it in the
morning, just pop open your
workbook or open your phone, and
that funnel announcement
is right there for
you to look at.
So let's just run the
query very quickly.
Again, so this isn't a massive,
massive data set, but
it's pretty big.
And obviously, we're running
this for our other games as
well on much larger data sets.
This is about 200
million rows.
So it's running, and
there we go.
So all of our interesting data
that we were interested in
about these different events
throughout our funnel, we've
tracked that, we split it by
Tier 1 countries and non-Tier
1, which is basically
English speaking
and not English speaking.
And we can see the results
visualized on our graph below.
So that's how easy it is,
really, to take these massive
data sets and actually produce a
workbook, a spreadsheet that
everybody knows how to access,
and really get this important
data in front of the teams
that are working on
the games every day.
Great.
So we're going to switch
gears a little bit now.
Again, that was a relatively
simple example of what you can
do to hook BigQuery up to
spreadsheets using Apps Script.
There's a lot of other things
you can do with Apps Script as
well, so definitely
have a look at it.
You can convert those
spreadsheets to PDFs, you can
email them to everybody.
There's loads and loads you
can do with them, so
definitely have a good
look at that.
So now we're going to talk a
little bit about how we build
tools that kind of industrialize
our learning.
So we do do a ton of
ad hoc analysis.
We've got four or five analysts
on our team that are
looking at our data
every single day.
All right, that's what
we've looked at.
But the next thing we're going
to look at is how we take
those learnings and how we build
tools that also interact
with our data to kind of
automate optimizations that we
see or automate tooling
that can help us.
And so the first one we're going
to talk about is a tool
that is called Mailman.
It's an engagement tool, and
it's built with App Engine.
So App Engine--
we get asked this
a lot as well.
Why do we use App Engine?
If anybody wants to go for a
beer later, I can talk to for
about two hours on all the
reasons why I love App Engine.
App Engine is fantastic, and
integrating it with other
Google services really
make it even better.
But just simply, if we had to
boil it down into a couple of
points, it's super productive,
right?
So I think I've said this
already today, but we just
like to focus on the problems
and leave some of the heavy
lifting to the Google
Cloud Platform.
And it's pretty powerful,
particularly for small teams
that are trying to grow
their businesses.
You need every minute of every
day on your products, not on
infrastructure.
The deployment model's
really cool.
All of our guys love the
deployment model.
We can't actually take advantage
of it as much as,
say, if you had a website that
you could, but we still make
very, very good use of it.
And then, of course, scale.
We mentioned this
once or twice.
We're going to mention
it again.
We cannot integrate with any
service that we don't believe
can scale along with us, because
we're always planning
for success.
We're expecting big numbers, big
traffic, big concurrency.
And if we're going to build
tools that run alongside our
games that our games platform's
going to be
speaking to at that sort of
level, we have to make the
right decisions.
And we feel very, very
good about our
choice of App Engine.
We've been working with it
for about two years now.
So Mailman, just to dig into--
this is just one of the
tools we've built.
We've built a number.
We decided to focus on
these two today.
So Mailman really is an
automated delivery mechanism
or delivery tool
for messaging.
It's really important
within our games.
People aren't playing
our games all
day, and that's healthy.
Some of them actually do, which
we're worried about, but
most of them don't, right?
Most of them are normal people,
and they come and go,
and they play a lot of
different games.
And so when we do our ad hoc
analysis, and we see the sorts
of drop-off points that maybe
are concerning to us, and we
see where people get stuck
within the game, sometimes
it's too late for us.
And because they got stuck in
the game at a certain point
that we've now identified,
they're not
planning on coming back.
And so this is when we have to
basically reach out to them.
And this is just one
case, right?
We reach out to our players all
the time through email,
through push notifications and
Facebook notifications.
So the logical components
of Mailman are lists.
Lists really answer the who.
So the powerful bit about
lists is that lists are
basically groups of message
recipients, so
they represent players.
And the list can be defined
with a query.
So anything we can write a query
for, anything that we
turn up in our ad hoc analysis,
we can just define a
new list with a query.
We use a little bit of
templating to make sure that
we can use those same queries
over and over daily, if they
need to be refreshed
daily, but it's a
pretty powerful thing.
And what actually happens
technically under the hood
when one of those lists are
created is that under the
hood, we basically make
a query to BigQuery.
And for those of you that are
familiar with App Engine, we
store the results, no matter how
large they are-- we store
those results in
the Blobstore.
And so jobs, when they
actually run--
the messaging jobs--
this is really where we take
advantage of App Engine's
scale and parallelism, because
we make use of the MapReduce
API and the pipeline APIs, and
that means that essentially,
we can spin up a lot of
instances to go away and map
over the results that we got
back from our query.
And so jobs really represent--
if lists are the who, then jobs
really answer the what,
the when, and the where, because
what happens when this
MapReduce job runs across all
these instances that just sort
of fire up magically is that for
every single recipient and
message that we're going to
send, we enqueue a task.
And so sometimes we run huge,
huge volumes of messaging,
whether it's email, push
notifications, Facebook
notifications.
You could very easily run a job
one night that's going to
be to millions of users.
And App Engine can handle
that pretty seamlessly.
And one of the things you'll
find when you start working
with App Engine is that there's
so many great APIs and
services that are made available
to you when you
build on that platform.
And so one of the ways in which
we-- there's a feature
called ETA, and ETA essentially
means that you can
specify the earliest time
that you want a
specific task to run.
And so we actually use the ETA
feature within the task use to
make sure that part of our query
on that list, one of the
columns of data that comes
back for every row
is actually a hint.
And it hints to us what time of
day we should actually send
out a message to make sure that
we get the highest chance
that a user's going to respond
to that and engage with that
message and come back
to the game.
And so we use a lot.
And obviously, we deliver across
the different channels.
So that's Mailman.
The next one we're going to talk
to you about-- this is
the last one--
is called Cobra, and Cobra is
also built on App Engine.
So Cobra's really interesting
because as you can imagine,
once your game's mature--
you launch a game, it's out
there for three or six months.
You're doing loads
of optimizations.
You really start to push it.
It's getting bigger and
bigger and bigger.
And slowly, what you see
happening is that you can't
just address users that
are, say, right on
the bleeding edge.
And you can't really just
address users that are on day
one or day two or day three.
But there's lots of different
strategies that you want to
deploy to make sure that you
have the best chance at
monetizing users at all of
the different stages
of their life cycle.
And so that's what Cobra
does for us.
Cobra is basically a pricing and
promotions engine which is
aware of players' profiles.
Cobra is loosely integrated
with BigQuery, but is also
heavily integrated with
our games platform.
And the other thing that it does
is it acts as a middleman
through all the transactions.
No matter what the platform,
all of our transactions
securely flow through Mailman,
are authenticated and
validated, and then
they proceed.
So if we think about the pricing
and promotions engine,
what's actually happening today
is a very iterative
process where we go away and
we do a lot of ad hoc
analysis, and from that ad hoc
analysis, we come up with
strategies.
So different pricing and
promotion strategies that we
want to basically program into
Cobra, and then deploy.
And when someone actually does
interact with one of these
offers, or a promotion, or a
response to maybe a subtle
change in some of the pricing,
we record that.
So they make a purchase, it's
tagged with a bunch of
information about the
configuration that they
responded to, and that flows
down into our games platform,
which, again, nightly, comes
back up into BigQuery.
And so we do a lot of manual
iterative processes there.
And that works really,
really well.
But one of the next things that
we're looking at is how
we can use something called the
Prediction API, and this
is another from Google which
I'm told is really, really
heavily used internally, and not
used that much externally.
But we definitely have
a use case for it.
So just at a super high level,
because we're running out of
time, the Prediction API kind
of has two functions.
If you have a model--
so you've got a lot of raw data,
which obviously we do,
and many of you, I would
imagine, have as well--
and you think that if you did
some analysis on that data,
you might be able to come up
with some statistically
significant indicators
of an outcome.
So for us, within Cobra, that
might be, this user's profile
looks like this right now.
Which type of offer do I think
they're most likely to convert
with, or to convert on?
So basically, you just put
a bunch of data in cloud
storage, you point that at
the training endpoint.
Prediction will suck up all
the data, will train
the model for you.
And when it's complete, you can
actually query that model.
So you can query that
statistical model with,
essentially, what would be a
row of data-- so a row of
these features.
And that would try and
predict what that
example value might be.
So Cobra with Prediction.
You can kind of see how
that would work.
And so the way in which we might
use it, or one of the
ways in which we might use it,
is to just help us train on
our financial data, train on our
profiles data, and try and
help us make even better
decisions about what kind of
offers to surface to players
based on where they are in
their lifetime.
And that's a pretty
powerful thing.
So that's something we're
experimenting with, and
hopefully, maybe next year, we
can come back in and talk
about how that went.
So just to sort of recap, my big
thing is, we've grown the
social team at Gamesys from
about 4 people sitting in a
little hallway to 100 people
that occupy most of a floor.
And I think one of the ways in
which we've done that is that
we try and stand on the
shoulders of giants, and not
try and replicate a
lot of work that
can be done by others.
And these are fantastic
products.
And if you invest the time into
understanding how they
work and what they can do for
you, you'll spend less time on
all the boring, painful stuff.
And you'll really be able to get
at your data, build really
cool tools, and focus
on your game,
which I think is paramount.
MATT MCNEILL: Great.
Thanks Tom.
I hope you got a sense of some
of the insight that data is
really bringing to gaming.
I can see that I'm going to lose
another six months of my
life when this game launches.
But I think there's some trends
that I'm seeing across
the industry, and one of the
things I'd say is, every
successful game company seems
to have three components.
The first is, obviously, the
technology, and that's often
the obvious one where
people start.
Hey, what technology, which
platforms do we choose?
But it's what you
do on top of it.
There's obviously the marketing
department and the
user acquisition side--
critically important.
But the thing I think that is
somewhat neglected, where
there's a real opportunity, is
in this area of analytics.
And one thing I'd say about
the Google platforms--
not just the Cloud Platform
that I'm involved in, but
actually all of Google's
services--
are helping game developers
and players
across a whole suite.
The Cloud Platform,
particularly, I think Tom
really brought out
what's important.
The platform is something,
really, which we built for us
here at Google.
This is our success.
And our strategy over the last
18 months is to externalize
that so that people
can use it.
So for me, personally, it's
really exciting to see the
work people like Tom, and
actually many of you in the
audience, are really starting to
do to build in a different
way and into the future, not
just of gaming, but technology
as a whole.
So I know we've had a
little bit of time.
I can see we've got about four
minutes on the clock for Q&A.
So we'll take some questions
now, but if you've got
anything else, we'll be at
the Cloud booth later on.
So any questions now?
We'll take a few.
Otherwise, we can
grab some beers.
Yeah, question here.
AUDIENCE: Did you start with
BigQuery, or did you have to
migrate over from
another RDBMS?
And if so, what challenges
did you see?
TOM NEWTON: For this sort of
work, to try and work with
data sets that are this big,
within some of the other
relational database services
that are out
there, we really struggled.
We really struggled.
And we also spent a lot
of time just trying
to make sure that--
we ran into so many different
problems along the way.
Particularly, when we started
some of these games, we never
thought we'd generate
this much data.
And at the time, we didn't
really have a good
understanding of the fact that
recording all this data at
this fine grain a level
was really necessary.
And so when we started looking
at BigQuery, we were using
MySQL databases, and that worked
relatively well to a
certain point.
But also, it required a fair
amount of maintenance and
human intervention and sysadmins
and experts with
that technology.
And we just want
to make games.
We don't want to have a bunch
of guys on the team that are
constantly focused on trying
to maintain these pieces of
software, not when there are
services like this that are
out there that you can leverage
that just make life
that much easier-- and to be
fair, are way more powerful,
and come with fantastic APIs.
So I hope that answers
your question.
We can talk to you a little bit
more about it afterwards.
AUDIENCE: I have one
more for you, too,
if I can get a chance.
TOM NEWTON: Sure.
MATT MCNEILL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So you have these ETL processes
that you're running
at the end of the day
or something, right?
And then basically, you're using
all this infrastructure
as a sort of [? all up ?] queue,
and you have all the
services that you
run out of it.
So I'm curious as to what were
the technical reasons for the
new games that you're making
that you didn't choose just to
build the whole thing on the
Google Cloud Platform and
avoid having your own
servers right now?
So were there lower latency
things, or some technological
things that were missing?
Because then it would avoid
having to do the ETL extract
at the end, and then run your
own App Engine processes, and
then extract that again out,
and putting it back in.
TOM NEWTON: So, sorry.
The question is, why don't we
build the games themselves on
App Engine or on Google
Cloud Platform?
AUDIENCE: What are the technical
features that are
missing from there?
TOM NEWTON: Well, for App
Engine, for games that require
bidirectional socket
communication, you're not
going to be able to do
that on App Engine.
It's scaled at the moment
not particularly well.
But now with Compute Engine
coming along, there's
absolutely no reason why you
can't build an entire game
stack on the Google
Cloud Platform.
I think the thing to remember
is that we started building
social games about 4 and 1/2
years ago, and built up a
platform on another provider.
And we've got a lot
of code there.
We can leverage that.
We can build games
really, really
quickly on that platform.
But to be honest, I'm
dying to find a game
that sort of fits--
maybe one of our next ones--
that we can actually build
with App Engine, if
it makes sense.
If it doesn't require
bidirectional sockets.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So two questions.
What are you guys using
to visualize the data?
Is it all just spreadsheets
with queries
and put into a chart?
Are you using any other
tools to visualize it?
TOM NEWTON: We kind of let
people pick and choose what
tools they want to use.
So we have been fairly heavy
users of Tableau in the past.
Some of our analysts just like
to work within Microsoft Excel
sometimes, and they use the
connector for Excel, and they
do a lot of visualizations
in there.
But for the most part, to be
honest, our core dashboards
and some of our most, I'd say,
insightful information sits
within these dashboards that
we put together for each
product now.
And a lot of them are ad hoc
analysis that are actually
done by the analysts, so they
can choose how they want to
visualize it and then circulate
it to the teams.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was actually wondering if
you can speak a little bit
about the predictive models that
you were showing there.
It wasn't clear, at least to me,
if that was something that
was done within the App Engine,
or is that something
that you're doing external?
And what kind of tools are
you using for that?
TOM NEWTON: Sure.
So I kind of rushed through
that, I apologize.
The Prediction API is
actually another
API provided by Google.
And we can talk a little bit--
oh, we have to get offstage.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TOM NEWTON: I'll come and have
a chat with you about that.
AUDIENCE: OK, yeah.
Sounds good.
MATT MCNEILL: OK, are we
OK to have a chat at
the booth maybe later?
I'm just thinking that we're
probably timed out here.
But thanks, Tom.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.
And if you have any questions,
please come by the booth.
[APPLAUSE]